[Music]
Ukraine's second biggest city now the
latest front line in the war with Russia
[Music]
Street battles are now underway after
Russian tanks and troops moved into
Hakeem on Sunday some of their hardware
destroyed and fierce fighting
people have been told not to leave their
homes but not just because of the
military advance
Ukraine says Russian forces blew up this
pipeline nearby and people have been
warned to keep inside to protect
themselves from the toxic smoke
the blast in the pipeline in Hakeem
happened during a wave of Russian
attacks on airfields and oil and gas
facilities analysts say this is a new
phase in The Invasion Russian troops are
trying to take over the vasel key of Air
Base where an oil Depot is on fire after
being hit by a Russian missile the site
is 40 kilometers from the capital cave
you have seen that during the whole day
there were attacks from ballistic
missiles including to our airport which
we have contained and now they are
continuing shelling but all will be good
the night will not be easy not here
neither in Kiev but we will withstand
Air Raid Sirens have been sounding
throughout Kiev where there have been
loud explosions people are crowding into
shelters and Metro stations below ground
fears of an all-out assault on the city
haven't yet materialized
the curfews in place until Monday
morning
but Russia maintains it has made
advances in two and around several
cities in the south
defense Ministry released these pictures
of its forces between Hassan and
berianski I pay special tribute to those
heroically performing their military
duty during the Special Operation to
provide assistance to the People's
Republic of Don bass these days
the Kremlin said a Russian delegation
had arrived in Belarus for talks with
Ukrainian officials a move rejected by
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
yes
if you didn't have this aggressive
actions from your territory you could
have talked and Minsk in your town this
is the truth that's the situation to
talk between neighbors and now you have
made your choice it depends on you
that's why now you're saying no to Minsk
other places could be a springboard for
talks want to talk we want to meet to
end this war zolenski has accused the
Russians of deliberately choosing
tactics to hurt his people in a conflict
that's already displaced a quarter of a
million of them Alexia O'Brien Al
Jazeera
let's take a look at who controls what
right now in Ukraine Russian troops
began attacking the country on Friday
from Belarus in the north Russia in the
East and Crimea in the south is the full
range of Russia's offensive marked in
red Russian forces also entered from
neighboring Belarus through the area
around the Chernobyl nuclear plant on
the second day of the invasion it's the
site of the world's worst nuclear
disaster
street fighting has broken out in the
capital Kiev where people have been
urged to take shelter that's despite the
fact Ukrainian troops blew up several
Bridges leading into the city to slow
the progress of Russian armored columns
well Andrew Simmons is in the Viv in
Western Ukraine with more on the
pipelines that have been targeted
well south of Kiev there has been an oil
facility blown up uh the night sky
illuminated by that fire which was well
as far as I'm hearing now is still
Ablaze also a pipeline near hakive
that's the second City in Ukraine in a
terrible State not helped by this gas
pipeline are being attacked and the
first Deputy head of administration in
Kiev is saying that there are clashes
with saboteurs as they're called thought
to be undercover Russians who are using
sleeper cells or something like that
which is constantly referred to by the
information Ministry and other officials
but these so-called saboteurs are set
upon by anybody available there can be
civilians uh with with free handout guns
or it can be other parts of a security
forces that's happening a lot and we're
hearing that some of the explosions some
of the attacks are are down to these
saboteurs they could be special forces
we don't have full details on it but
what we do know and as a network is that
it is incredibly dangerous anywhere
particularly in Kiev obviously but
anywhere in the country not just because
of the Russian attacks but because of
the level of stress and tension uh with
uh field operations going on to try to
find these saboteurs or to try to find
aggressors as they're described we came
we're the latest one of the latest to
come into a situation it by no means is
it the most serious but our arrival in
this city last night was within minutes
of the curfew coming down the right side
of the curfew coming down but we will
effectively ambushed by armed police
from several directions or with
automatic guns their safety off
definitely of a pistol at the head of my
colleagues and indeed myself the pistol
was off safety and directly point
pointed and they were really stressed
and it was if you hadn't had your arms
up we felt that the worst could have
happened it went on for nearly half an
hour we were obviously had our Bonafide
uh documents with us but this went on
Dorsey Jabari joins us live now to get
the view from the Russian Capital so
dorsa as far as this ongoing discussion
of the possibility of talks what more
are we hearing on that from the Russian
side
well according to the Kremlin they were
waiting for the ukrainians to respond
until 12 GMT today there is a Russian
delegation made up of members from the
president's office as well as a foreign
Ministry and the Russian defense
Ministry who are now currently in the
Southeastern city of gomol in Belarus
they said that they are there because
they are ready to have talks with the
Ukrainian officials now they picked the
city of gomal according to the
belarussian president Alexander
lukashenko he says that the ukrainians
chose to have the the talks be held in
that City instead of the capital Minsk
but the ukrainians have officials have
said that that is not true and that the
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
says that they are not going to have any
kind of discussions with Russian
officials in Belarus he provided a
number of other cities as possibilities
but he said that they will not go to
Belarus to have any kind of dialogue
with Russia because Belarus is one of
the countries that Russian troops have
entered into Ukraine from and he says we
cannot in all honestly have any contact
with them and to go into that area would
be very much against what they believe
in now the uh Russian President Vladimir
Putin we understand has just spoken to
the Israeli Prime Minister Natalie
Bennett who has offered to mediate the
talks between Ukraine and Russia and
Vladimir Putin has said that according
to the Kremlin during that conversation
he again said that the Russians are
ready to talk to Ukrainian officials but
in Belarus and he also explained the
ongoing operation that the Russian
military is involved with in the donbass
region in eastern Ukraine to the Israeli
Prime Minister this all of course is um
at a time when the Russians have said
that they are not willing to stop the
military operation as they call it in
Ukraine even if they do have any kind of
dialogue with the Ukrainian officials
but what is not clear is who do they
want to talk to within the
administration in Kiev because Vladimir
Putin has said that he doesn't recognize
that Vladimir zielinski as the
legitimate leader and he is just a
puppet of the West he questions his
legitimacy on a regular basis so the
Kremlin hasn't specified who they're
willing to have talks with but in the
meantime they said that if any talks
continue the military operation will not
stop
a German chancellor Olaf Schultz has
announced a major boost to defense
spending that's after the rare move to
allow military aid to be sent to Ukraine
Schultz warned further measures could be
placed on Russia if it fails to change
course
from
the sanctions package against Russia is
unprecedented Putin will not change his
actions overnight but very soon the
Russian leadership will fill the higher
price they will pay our sanctions do
work as financial sector has been hit
hard in recent days it was Putin not the
Russian people who decided to start a
war or Dominic Kane joins me live now
from Berlin for more on that speech from
the German Chancellor so Dominic we saw
a quite a hardening of Germany's
position there from Mr Schultz
particularly in the area of German
defense spending
what we heard from Chancellor Schultz is
something that we've heard from very few
German chancellors since the end of the
second world war an open call for
re-armament of the German military but
this time not as an agent of aggressive
intent by the German government rather
as a reassurance to EU allies and
specifically NATO allies what we also
heard from Mr Schatz is a determination
as soon as possible to meet the
requirement that was agreed to by Angela
Merkel back in 2014 at the Wales NATO
Summit two percent of the budgets of
this country to be spent on defense
Angela Merkel had the best part of eight
years to achieve it and never could now
Mr Schultz says that the situation in
Ukraine is so bad that Germany must meet
it as quickly as possible investing a
hundred billion euros in the German
military in the coming years and there
were also many messages from Mr Schultz
to Vladimir Putin very unambiguous
messages to Vladimir Putin effectively
saying that Mr Schultz believed that
Vladimir Putin is intent on building his
own personal Empire with what he called
spheres of influence for the Russian
Federation harking back to the battle
days as it were of the Cold War and so
what we have here hasn't is effectively
all our shots ripping up the Strategic
Playbook that successive German
governments have worked by since the
fall of the Berlin Wall since the end of
the Cold War at completely different
direction and it's not just in so far as
defense spending is concerned there is
also in its way a reference perhaps a
coded reference to the policy of Angela
Merkel you have from Mr Schultz an
acceptance that Germany is over-reliant
on Russian gas we knew already that in
the course of the last few days that
he'd said that the Nordstrom 2 pipeline
linking Russia with Germany was not
going to be switched on the
certification process was gone until
further notice but he's gone much
further than that and said that Germany
intents as fast as possible to build two
very large new liquid natural gas
Terminals and then to buy in as much LNG
from other worldwide suppliers again as
fast as possible in order to try to
reduce as much as possible the Reliance
that Germany has on Russian natural gas
remember it's a very large fraction of
Germany's energy is currently supplied
by Russia so very much we heard Mr
Schultz talk about turning points that
this is what the war in Ukraine is a
turning point for Germany and his speech
marks a turning point for Germany a real
as I said before ripping up of the
Playbook that's obsessive governments
have worked by that is how important
what's happened today in Parliament was
Dominican life for us in Berlin thanks
darling